[Music]
texas is freezing you know wyoming is
freezing new york is freezing true
they doing dancing the streets in new
york and she was so stupid it was stupid
it was [ __ ] hate de blasio though
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
those honestly de blasio and cuomo have
said italian politicians back 50 years
yeah one hundred percent fifty years
they sent him back i'm not elected
bro i love italians italians
love italians if you ask an italian what
is the best
cheese it's from italy what is the best
wine it's from italy what is the best
vacation destination
it's somewhere in italy everything they
love italian so much
there are two italians not even italians
[ __ ] with
mayor de blasio governor cuomo you ask
any italian bank nah they're [ __ ]
dead to us now
dead really they lo oh yeah they lost
the italian everybody was sucking
cuomo's dick early in the pandemic which
i also was obviously
we didn't know that he was killing these
[ __ ] old people bro did you hear the
[ __ ] that came out about that
uh that he lied about the numbers of
deaths in the nursing home and then
apparently
one of his like tell me where i'm wrong
one of his like press secretaries or
whatever said aids his time
he said they asked him about it and
everybody just froze like are we
supposed to hand this information over
and
he didn't want trump to send the justice
department in there
yeah right so they basically froze
didn't hand over the information
didn't say it so they deflated the
number of deaths
by like 50 i guess it was in that like
little
yeah yeah yeah and listen i don't blame
him
for old people dying of corona because
that's who dies of corona i don't blame
him for
um like corona being spread through
these old people homes because those are
the people who are most vulnerable and
most willing to get it right like
and we don't know what the [ __ ] to do in
the beginning yep so it's you can't be
psychic
right i do blame him for
knowingly suppressing the amount of
deaths fell and then i'm pretty sure
he wrote a [ __ ] book about how great
he handled the pandemic
is that a fact please can you look this
up i'm pretty sure
i hate this [ __ ] yo bro that is
that [ __ ]
that is true i hate that yeah yeah all
these actors that were sucking this dick
tweeting about how great he was where
are you right now
are you at now no i don't know morning
they're dead grandparents
because of that chimp nippled sauce
monkey
[ __ ] chimp-nippled sauce monkey
andrew cuomo governor cuomo embarrassing
literally killed new york city man
killed the jewel the west dude i talked
did you talk to friends back home
he did write a book about the battle
that new york had with covet
yeah you leave that little part out yeah
he must have left that little part out
where he was just
killing [ __ ] old people i i don't
think he would include that the battle
of people born in 1812 where's that
chapter but it is crazy right what a
piece of [ __ ] dude piece of [ __ ]
he killed he killed new york but because
he's a coward
yeah because these [ __ ] have
political aspirations
outside of where they are right so they
were too
scared it's not like they're worried
about people dying
right and maybe it is i don't want to
put all that out there i'm sure there's
concern about people dying of course
and everybody nobody wants there to be
deaths but
clearly he was willing to hide deaths
from the public
in order to make sure that his political
career continued on the same path right
so we've proven he's done that for a
fact
yeah right he hid deaths so that he
wouldn't be culpable for those deaths
so he could continue doing what he's
doing and ascending to who knows
a potential presidential run et cetera
right so he's willing to put
his own political progress ahead of
deaths yep we know that
now this is why he's a coward in my
opinion
okay because you have a guy
who is not willing to roll the dice
on the success of the state right and
this is where i got to give credit to
desantis the
governor of florida right he is willing
to roll the dice
yes right he's willing to roll the dice
and he's going to take all the
responsibility on me
it's on me if it goes wrong if florida
implodes
and there's just this infestation of
corona and 50 of people [ __ ] die
that's on one guy
governor rick desantis right he rolled
the [ __ ] dice
for his state right maybe his
aspirations to be present i never heard
him speak about it before nobody ever
brought his [ __ ] name up
it was only cuomo and gavin newsom right
everybody like oh my god the way the
cuomo's handling
the pandemic oh my god gavin newsom is
so presidential who are the two least
likely people to be president
the two [ __ ] most fraudulent people
who killed
the two most important cities in america
probably the crown jewel
definitely dc i get but definitely new
york
definitely la up there and both of those
cities are dead
yeah entertainment every entertainer
lived in new york or l.a
all of them gone yeah and then i mean
you look at this and you look at florida
and everybody's moving to florida texas
or florida texas
florida and i'm telling you it is a
ballsy decision he will get credit
but you don't see his name spoken that
much but people don't realize this like
the d and i know it sounds like i'm
stroking dicks but i am stroking dick
the guy
saved [ __ ] lives when i call my
friends and my family back home
in new york they're so depressed dude
yeah they're so [ __ ] depressed off
it is brutal it's already hard in new
york in the winter awful
you can't do anything now yep now
obviously there are
people that they have to stay there you
know what i mean they just have to right
financial restrictions not everybody has
the ability to just up and move
right but politicians could
could do things they know that they can
do things because there's examples of
them being done
right here in florida yep they know that
they could open things up 100
they choose not to and they are crushing
the souls of the people back home man
yeah it's [ __ ] i don't understand how
somehow it's not
it's not like a thing that we're allowed
to talk about the cuomo's [ __ ] up this
entire thing
lockdowns are way too strict those
people get celebrated and i just think
there can be a happy medium
between hey we're not allowed to wear
masks at the gym
and hey i'm shutting down indoor dining
in new york which is the restaurant
capital of the world maybe
and you're all just gonna have to figure
it out this is florida this is what
florida does right
young people go [ __ ] it i'mma get corona
yeah that is the
policy of young people yeah maybe you
guys have experienced something
different but as far as i'm concerned
every person under 40 let's say not even
just young every person under 40 just
goes
yeah i had that [ __ ] back in the day i
have yet to meet a single person
in florida that hasn't had it
they i i mean listen would they say one
thing about the numbers
about the amount i don't know i don't
know if i essentially believe it yeah
every single person that i've met here
under 40 has said they had it
it is the sweden of the u.s yeah i guess
he's not locking down nothing you get it
you get it we're going to be immune at
some point
it's true now the old people mask up
i always see old people messed up and
then old people take that [ __ ] seriously
yep
why is that not the strategy of every
single state in the united states
every single state or city around the
world
it works florida is the example
i think we're in the lower half florida
is in the lower half of covid deaths or
even covid
um cases i heard something there's two
things i think they're 27th
my two things might explain one i'm with
joe rogan on the vitamin d makes a big
difference though yeah
man this is the sunshine state didn't it
and two
humidity i've heard can really help with
like the severity of covert
if it's high humidity miami got both of
those so if you get it it might not be a
severe
again i just think there's a happy
medium between [ __ ] you we're not
wearing masks i refuse to wear masks
this is all made up
and hey we're taking this so seriously
we're shutting down everything because i
want to be president one day
who was the last italian president i'm
not electing some [ __ ] italian for
president come on
franklin delano roosevelt was he italian
no but delano sounds kind of like
probably his half by half no i don't
know if we've ever had an italian we're
not gonna
jfk i don't trust y'all with it now he
was an irish he was irish but he was
mobbed up i trust an irish before i
trust an italian
yeah but i actually like italians
they're president yeah you know i kind
of no for president i like president
explain
sell me on this trump trump's italian
he's not but he is
okay everything about trump is is just
italian yeah that wasn't all great
but i liked it
[Laughter]
i like everything about his personality
i liked as a person yeah
yeah he's the funniest guy he's the
funniest guy [ __ ] playing of course
like how boring is twitter without him
i'm actually happy that he got acquitted
because hopefully he gets active again
is he gonna be allowed back on oh
they're saying he's not allowed back
he's kicked off twitter it's not because
of an impeachment no no he got back on
twitter
when yeah he got back on twitter like
the day after or something like that oh
really
i think twitter said if he runs again
they won't allow him to be on
really yeah that's interesting if you're
trump are you running again
if you lose twitter i don't think he's
running again you want to do that [ __ ]
you really want to we didn't think he
wanted to be president once we didn't
think he wanted to be president twice
yeah yeah is biden live
[Laughter]
have you all heard from buying is biden
that you sent us in the topic list oh
yeah but you didn't finish and i'm so
happy to know yeah the last word is
alive yeah yeah no but is he because i
haven't heard from him
no chance like is he dead no she's got
to be he's been dead since [ __ ]
march march 2018 2018.
you